[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va bien on voit tout de suite que je
suis pas du tout du même groupe
cette bourse est debout les gars
commencent à voir les fruits séchés qui
squattent aucune théorie non les plus
belles mais tout ça est que toi il
connaît par le témoin je vais faire
partie du jury dès que vous n'aimez plus
vous buzz est d'accord il ya gilles
verdez qui veut faire partie peut-être
de votre prochain groupe
voilà où matthieu delormeau vous buzz et
dès que vous n'aimez pas d'accord et on
vous a préparé quelque chose il s'est
entraîné toute l'après-midi a préparé
une chorégraphie et pour faire partie de
votre boss bourde matthieu delormeau
vous pouvez également y aller parce que
vous ferez votre prestation juste après
[Musique]
alors c'est leur métier qu'est ce que
vous en avez pensé franchement j'y vais
en chercher le deuxième pour comparer
parce que c'est dur de comparer un
premier temps voir l'attention hier il a
tenu quand même vous avez fait 15
secondes un dedans mais je peux
continuer dans ce bon version
[Applaudissements]
en surf des neiges
[Musique]
oh
ah bon
oracle de l'âme aucun droit gagnant pour
l'implication beau baba moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est que vous nous fassiez
voilà un petit remix voilà de toutes les
chansons parce qu'on veut faire actifs
est-ce que vous pouvez nous prépare un
petit truc où nous avait préparé un vrai
truc de boisement de la version doit la
version voilà depuis la version 2.0
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'suis pas
j'ai pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bath
seul parti un jour sans tout
non
de travaux l'été
tarifs
alors bravo les gars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]